et
la mise en place par delphine alors là
c'est fini je ne peux plus faire une
école départ les maires vont ramasser
leurs proches denis turrel nsa paradis a
refusé de témoigner mais un a gros sur
la patate
savary j pas mais ça s'est passé
beaucoup plus tard itaste ardues aussi
vous me voulez mon fonds de commerce la
dent mais tout le monde connaît ma fille
rassure-toi sous celle d'andy moi je le
temps venant du courrier et d'un va
téléphoner pour savoir pourquoi tu
touchais pas les vedettes dix mois cette
enfance au fond quand moi elle s'est
laissé un petit complexe parce que
c'était une espèce d'amertume quand même
non je ne suis pas du tout amer je filme
très mécontents les mécontents de moi
ouais enfin libération le nouvel obs
c'est quand même un joli tout alors je
vais te dire libération je lis tous les
matins on a très bien fait et puis
je lis à l'autre bord pour me faire une
opinion non non j'étais un peu
réconcilié avec tous ces gens là quoique
non juste comment dirais-je
avec le temps on à la juste mesure des
choses et tu leur dis bon soir quand tu
les vois chez castel le soir s'ils
arrivent en voiture je vais voir tous
les ans fin je les vois quand je chante
je les connais depuis dix ans à un
moment tu leur en voulez plus quand ben
oui parce qu'à un moment de sa carrière
on est d'une susceptibilité vis-à-vis de
la personne à tous les gens qui vous
attaquent on voudrait les voir voué aux
gémonies clouée sur des poteaux de
douleur puis en réalité avec quand même
la sagesse qui vous vient qu'on
s'aperçoit que tout ça c'est une vaste
farce et que ce n'est pas très important
et qu'il faut reconnaître quand on fait
un métier public que les gens vous tombe
dessus
tu te rends compte que c'est juste la
semaine il ya des articles comme ça qui
me fait ça ait fana route c'est que des
témoignages spontanés
on va voir si les témoignages spontanés
je vais couper les moyennes vont
commencer petit voyou bien je n'ai donné
un cachet bien sûr si j'essaie d'arrêter
en dix mois
non quand même là bon c'est vrai qu'il
ya une certaine sérénité au mieux un
pinceau seraient des diables permet par
exemple quand à fena ils ont toujours
plus et rentes excédant ses films que
tes émissions record est là et là j'ai
une seule critique et cesser demain on
fait du mal quand même
oui ça fait beaucoup de ça fait ça fait
beaucoup de peine mais c'est pas très
important
et puis dans notre métier il faut avoir
la peau comme du cuir
ouais sinon il vaut mieux pas le faire
parce qu'on est à plus à souffrir toute
sa vie c'est vrai que n'importe qui dans
cette profession a le droit de dire lui
c'est un raga lui s'éteint c'est ta
misérable c'est cse ça fait partie
implicitement du contrat même dans la
rue des fois le 2 mai ministre ait joué
rien fait je fais ma gymnastique ce
matin et le mec il a baissé la glace il
m'a dit sale con il à partir il atteint
eur
contre reconnaît
alors quand il colle et bâclée mehdi
domine à un témoin qui les faux qu'il a
eu avant moi
1 oui bon c'est un mec remarquable oui
sauf que même rage de le mettre dehors
alors je sais pourquoi je sais c'est un
pde fort non non tu expliqueras après
les miens je veux pas le dire parce que
je veux pas balancer sur un copain dix
mois la première fois que j'étais
interviewé c'était dans une émission qui
s'appelait bain de minuit sur la sur la
fin j'étais plus amer envers
l'intelligentzia et il y avait quelque
chose dont tu parlais pas trop à
l'époque parce que ça venait d'arriver
cet état prises de position en 88 à la
concorde pour chirac et tu disais oui
c'est une erreur je veux pas en parler
les jeux j'ai vraiment je les fais par
un métier ouais bah ça ne concerne pas
avec chirac
ouais c'est une histoire que sur lequel
j'avais un poireau je veux pas qu'on en
parle